There were still three events left.
He would win the next event, diving.
He was a great diver.
He was sure he would win the diving event.
Bongo made his very best dive.
But he only scored 5 points.
The winner was the seal.
She scored 10 points.
Bongo was last.
Bongo was not worried.
There were still two events left.
He would win the next event, weightlifting.
He was very strong.
He was sure he would win the weightlifting event.
Bongo used all his strength to lift the barbells.
The elephant lifted much more.
The elephant was the winner.
Bongo was last.
Bongo was very worried.
There was only one event left.
He had to win it to get a gold medal.
He wasn't sure he could win the next event, gymnastics.
He was worried that the other animals were better gymnasts.
The cheetah went first.
He wasn't very good.
He scored three points.
The kangaroo was worse.
He scored two points.
The elephant was very clumsy and scored only one point.
It was Bongo's turn.
He was perfect.
He scored ten points and won a gold medal.